[Music]
hi everyone I'm Anthony Navarro I'm the
product manager for robotics at Udacity
I'm here to have a beer and talk about
robots with you so I'm gonna be reading
your talk here over on the live chat and
kind of answering any questions I can
about the robotics program we have about
Udacity in general about other robotics
topics career whatever you feel like so
I'll be watching this side and let me
know let me know what you think about
the program so far if you're in the
program if you're looking at signing up
for the program give me some give me
some feedback it looks like we've got
quite a few people from around the world
just looking at the different limb
favorite countries Brazil and Honduras
Montreal it's awesome China seems like
we got a good time then to get everybody
in here Korea Philippines
hopefully everybody's familiar with the
robotics program it's been here Udacity
since about March we've got one cohort
going forward and another one in
development right now we're sorry and
waiting to get applications in and
payments and then we're gonna get them
launched too so we're gonna have our
second cohort launching very soon here
we go we got questions popping up so how
Ross focused is it we do have a lot
based on Ross so the current term starts
with you know getting into Ross Ross
tutorials and teaching you really what
Ross is and how to program it and the
first term is all based in Python second
term we'll get more into C++ but since
Ross is used in many different
applications we thought it was very
important to actually go forward and you
know use Ross in there where do I think
that these things are jumping around on
me what do I think robotics is gonna be
in the next five years or beyond it's a
good question there's a lot of you know
traditional methods that are used in
robotics right now and deep learning is
obviously a very fascinating topic it
can solve a lot of problems and or at
least is being investigated to solve a
lot of problems it'll depend on you know
do we hit a plateau with that is it
gonna keep growing and so it's really
interesting to watch that field and see
the different applications because even
ideas like slam you see certain issues
that slam has getting moved over when
you go into deep learning you get rid of
those issues and so you get a better
performing system and you put it on a
GPU and it moves faster so there's a lot
of really interesting ideas and I think
what you're gonna see is these
applications across of course multiple
domains you know land air sea space but
then the communications architecture
between those is going to be very
important and how these systems interact
and so systems of systems is going to be
very important in the future how many
people are already in the program we
have a quite a few we had a few thousand
apply I don't I'd have to look at exact
numbers and everything but we have a
quite a few thousand that have applied
and we're hit we're waiting to see what
cohort two is gonna look like
as far as enrollment so we're really
excited to get another cohort going
though
well taking Udacity intro to programming
course be enough to get started in the
robotics course if not what intermediate
steps would you recommend to prepare for
the robotics course so intro to our
intro to programming will give you a
good foundational basics of robotics
however if you're you've never done a
lot of the math especially linear
algebra linear algebra is a very you
know physical type of math that has a
lot of applications in robotics that if
you're not familiar with that there's
gonna be more of a steep learning curve
we are investigating other ways that we
can you know get you from intro to
programming or other entry-level pieces
up to our more advanced nanodegrees like
self-driving car and robotics so stay
tuned and we'll see you know what
happens from that but absolutely if you
if you've never done programming before
intro to programming you're great
courses start with and I'm glad you're
here I'm glad you're following on to
some of the you know keeping up with the
community in robotics cuz these are the
people you want to keep kind of talking
to and see and if what you're interested
in is in the one of these areas hi there
I'm looking to Ford to buying a robotic
arm hardware any recommendation for
models and brands that's a really
wide-ranging question so there's tons of
robotic arm patents out there
cuca I used to work with some ABB
robotics I'm guessing you don't want to
buy a $20,000 hundred thousand dollar
arm and so I know that there are more
like hobbyist friendly arms out there I
don't have let me see I'm gonna Google
some stuff right here yeah there's some
good options out there that are on robot
looks like banana robotics a robot shop
that could at least give you something
to start with in the form of you know
tens to a couple hundred dollars so I
don't have any personal recommendations
I haven't done a lot with you know
robotic arms myself except industry side
so yeah say one that works and just you
know if you can get something that's
based now I guess I wouldn't you could
use it with everyone controller you have
but yeah I would just look to see what's
in your price range what is the
difference between machine learning and
robotics um a lot so robotics is kind of
its they're both of those are kind of
general terms and so
robotics should apply to everything from
technically your nest could be a rope
you could consider your nest a robot or
Lex or a robot machine learning is just
kind of a met a way that robots are
method that robots would use in order to
achieve a certain goal or to achieve
intelligent intelligence so when we have
these intelligent and autonomous systems
they need to learn in some way and so
there's been traditional algorithms that
we've done and then now a lot that is
going towards machine learning deep
learning and so different fields of AI
so machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence and artificial
intelligence is a tool that robots can
use to be smarter basically sorry I'm
looking for more questions you guys are
typing them fast so I got it what
programming languages use most in
robotics I would say in a lot of
robotics and embedded systems you're
gonna be looking at C++ and C you're
very important for optimization however
when you get into a lot of the learning
areas Python is really good for
prototyping so those are the two that I
would recommend and that's what we go
over in our course and when you go to
some employers are gonna really want to
see you know C++ and some robots if
they're only robots or certain companies
using it they're gonna use their own
language so it's a better better to have
a good understanding of how software
interacts with the hardware than it is
in a good language it's good to know
like C++ but also how does that language
interact with a hardware and what are
the restrictions in that pipeline I got
the Udacity sticker on my laptop from
Udacity it's I guess a perk of working
here how how do you make money with
robotics not working for a big company
umm I mean there's a lot of applications
you could if you with a robotics
education you could be a robotics you
could consult on robotics there's other
places where you could probably if you
have a really good idea you could look
at launching a Kickstarter campaign but
you know there is a lot that goes into
product ization of electronic hardware
so just keep that in mind
can i distinguish between starting in
August 16th and September 24th through
both semesters need to be taken
secularly or can there be a gap so the
two cohorts that we have starting the
August and the September cohorts they're
not they're not if you're gonna take
like they're not those aren't semesters
those are different groups starting
together so if a group of people are
gonna be starting on if you're gonna opt
to go put a deposit down and take the
September one you'll start in September
and theirs doesn't affect you in any way
if you start in August you know in
August you'll be going through September
so it's just a matter of the start date
that you want to do I think the
nanodegree in robotics will prepare you
for a career in robotics absolutely
that's the whole point that we you know
Udacity tried to push for is we want to
get you job ready so if you're coming
from absolutely nothing and the best
thing the best advice I always have for
people is go above and beyond make
yourself stick out do something
different if there's challenges if
there's extra projects you can do if
there is something that can
differentiate rajat away from others so
I actually started out as a self-driving
car student in the first cohort and one
of the opportunities I got to do was
lead the Thunder Hill racing team for
the self-driving car nanodegree that was
offered and so Udacity partnered with
poly sync and they put out this
challenge and I got selected to lead it
and it was an exciting experience that
gave me a huge amount to talk about in
the future to employers and really
everyone that not only am I doing this
nanodegree and so were you know many
other people but I also went above and
beyond did this and so my best advice is
if you really want a job in this area
same with you know students in
University don't do the bare minimum go
above and beyond set yourself apart and
you know make you know yourself really
attractive to employers yes the so it
seems like the robotics nanodegree focus
this is on software development however
harder development I assume it needs
hands-on training it yeah so there's a
kind of a software there's a stack of
disciplines when you get into robotics
which is one of the you know
very unique things about robotics you
kind of had this computer side of it you
have the electrical side and you have a
mechanical side we are not we're not
getting into any be a mechanical side of
things we're not getting into the in any
of the electrical side and even some of
the integration stuff while it will be
gone over with the robots you receive
you're not expected to write this
integration piece to make drivers work
per se so really our focus is on the
artificial intelligence in robotics and
kind of the algorithms that go along
with that so making robots smarter it's
kind of the focus is what this nano
degree is it's a nano degree Hardware
foot oriented or software oriented can
you talk about the flow of the course
and the projects yeah so it's more
software oriented like I just said the
flow is you're gonna kind of come in
you're gonna get used to you know a
RAAF's project and do something with a
little rover then there's a kinematics
portion we touch on controls and then
I'm sorry we touch on perception and so
that projects just been released to the
first cohort then we're gonna get into
controls a little bit more and then
we're gonna get into more deep learning
methods and then term to I won't get
into because we haven't announced it yet
but it is on the horizon so exciting
things there mmm this is actually
something I've seen I see a lot oh and
it jumped again sorry about that
do I need to be a robot or what do I
need to be a robotics expert okay sorry
first I'm ready do I need to be a
robotics expert James for that one no
absolutely not we don't expect you to
even have a familiarity with robots I
mean that's what we're here to teach you
we want you to have some familiarity
with math and programming but we'll
teach you the robotics concepts now what
do you need to be a robotics expert that
really depends on what you want so to me
there's two types of people out there in
engineering and you know in robotics and
everything you have your you know
specialists and you have your generalist
me personally I'm a generalist I like to
know a little bit about a lot of things
and be able to understand and touch on a
lot of different pieces but I'm not the
super deep dive into one area like to
say like path planning that you know
some people might want to do your
specialists are that person they're
gonna know one area extremely well
they're gonna be able to solve you know
they understand all the math in and out
of it solve really cool problems with
that
but they may not know how to do like the
communications architecture that's
completely fine because you need them to
solve the really hard problems in the
area that they know so to be an expert
it kind of depends on what you want are
you somebody who likes to focus on one
thing a little bit more do you like to
focus on multiple pieces so that's it's
kind of hard to say that we mean in the
robotics curriculum we touch on a lot of
different pieces and if there's
something that you really like doing
then dive in that wrap it hold a little
bit more and hopefully right now some of
the Udacity the Explorers content that
we put out there shows you a little bit
more of what's out there what techniques
are being used and you can find
something that you like a little bit
more how do you think deep learning can
be integrated into the more traditional
motion planning algorithms for robotics
for instance can it be used to come up
with a constraint constraint reject
trajectories I think deep learning can
be integrated into a lot of things but
is it the right answer for thing
everything that's something that I think
is still out there I'm personally very
interested in seeing where deep learning
takes us and I know there's a huge
interest from students to kind of do
more so looking at you know what else
can we do in deep learning we do have a
deep learning module coming up so be
excited about that but sure I mean you
could feed the robot positive positions
for a robotic arm and the Ender you know
where the end effector is as an output
and you could say use reinforcement
learning to achieve that and maybe you
can do better things with it maybe not
it's something that we'd have to play
with a little bit more to see really
what what are the strengths of deep
learning and where do they come out
answered the hard way so robotic Santa
degree is a little bit more software
Enid and thank you Kyle for linking the
medium post on there after taking this
program how likely are graduates to land
a robotics engineering position with the
hiring partner otherwise and where the
majority of operations look
opportunities location wise I haven't
looked at where all the opportunities
location-wise I actually came over here
from my former employer and we were a
partner on the robotics nanodegree and
so they have locations all over the
country robotics is all over the country
you have many many different types from
everything from farm to you know
everything cutting edge in Silicon
Valley to all over the world I mean
industrial robotics manufacturing
robotics Amazon's hiring robotics people
there's many many jobs everywhere and
the goal is to yes train you in this
discipline that's one of the reasons we
want to use Rob's and we want to use C++
in the course because employers are
asking for these things you know Python
is great it's nice it's simple but
understanding the constraints of C++ and
how your code actually interacts with
the hardware is very important to
employers so we do want to focus on that
in the course
our autonomous vehicles considered
robotics absolutely robotics or
autonomous vehicles are a subset of the
robotics field is this the first cohort
of the robotics and ER degree if not
what didn't didn't work well in the
first cohort this is the first cohort so
we're hopefully doing a great job by
your standards but if there's something
you're not liking please give us
feedback do you think I can get at a
nano degree while also taking courses in
a university absolutely I actually have
somebody that I knew that I met through
the self-driving car program that he was
a PhD student while he was taking the
self-driving car nano degree and then he
also jumped on to the Robo nano degree I
also know somebody who has been taking
two to three nanodegrees simultaneously
and so yeah absolutely it's it's up to
you I mean you put in the time you can
do it and so just you know that's kind
of your call on your subject and you
know but it's you do get a lot out of it
I do think where the university will
teach you a lot of theory we go into a
lot of application and how you could
actually use that in a job that you're
gonna get how many hours a week do you
expect a nano degree to take so and you
know thank you for answering Lynden we
say 10 to 15 hours and that's kind of a
general response but I would say it
really depends on your background if
you're I've known people who like again
coming from the self-driving car side
took a lot of time to go through term 1
and then I know somebody who completed
term 1 in a matter of three to four
weeks so really it depends on your
background but as an average estimate we
would say 10 to 15 hours I've currently
enrolled in the first term robotics
program and behind my schedule will that
affect my second term enrollment so if
you're behind schedule that's okay
as long as you can get all your projects
done by the term end date at the bottom
so each of the projects has their
completion day at the very bottom
there's a little bit buffer and then
there's a term completion date that's
what you really want to hit you got to
have all your projects and by that date
and if you can hit that then you should
be well on your way to term 2 I'm
interested in self-driving car is
nanodegree what are the prerequisites
okay
so I'm actually the program manager are
the
the product manager for self-driving car
as well so it's kind of the similar
similar pieces where you want to know
Python if you have a C++ background it's
gonna be beneficial to you as you get to
term two and three on that and then a
good understanding of calculus and
linear algebra because while we're not
asking you to like derive anything or
take integrals we do show you notation
in those kind of forms and if you aren't
familiar with that notation it's gonna
be a little bit more difficult now that
being said if you do get accepted to the
program and you're willing to take that
additional time on your own if you don't
have those gaps absolutely you know just
be prepared that you may be spending
more on that you know 15 to 20 hours
possibly than the 10 to 15 I applied it
was accepted but I'm a bit hesitant
about enrolling due to the fact that
it's expensive and there are no job
guarantees unlike other nanodegrees how
were you at addy
Udacity helped us out with this so one
of the things we've launched in our
classrooms that is a little bit
different from when I joined self you
know driving car cuz you know you vastly
changed quite a bit in the last year is
we have kind of career readiness so we
have projects that are optional projects
and supplemental to the core course
material that help you get ready so
we'll review your you know get our yeah
github LinkedIn will review your resume
we kind of give you these career
opportunities and then we also directly
link you with employers so the way that
looks you know from the employer side is
you know if you finish this nano degree
we put your name out and we advertise
you to employers and we give you a
chance to you know go and interview with
them we also look at hosting challenges
sometime to do the same thing but again
this is where you know if I have a
thousand you know Robotics a know degree
students and an employer wants to hire
ten how do you stand out and so that's
why I think it's the most important
message I can say is to you know really
go above and beyond and really you know
push forward in these areas what are a
few really cool applications of robotics
being worked on out there any game
changes being worked on absolutely I was
googling earlier some robotics stuff and
there's like a exoskeleton that I saw
that was using Amazon Alexa I think I
like space so I think all the stuff with
space and have
how we can handle the lack of
communication or like the latency
between communication is very
fascinating self-driving cars are well I
think are definitely interesting but I
also think it's really interesting the
communications between all these systems
so as you have systems become more
autonomous what really gets you the next
level even past a single you know piece
of autonomy is the system of systems and
so how do you have you know everything
from you know ground to air or from
water to air or talking to each other
and everything in between and sharing
this you know picture of you know its
environment to me that's extremely
exciting and that's very game-changing
there is no employment guarantee for the
standard degree
are there any stats you can discuss
regarding the percentage of students who
find jobs after the course is it
comparable to other courses so kind of
an early question asks because nobody's
completed our course not even the first
term yet really because it's nanodegrees
still an early phase we aren't we are
getting away from I think the job
guarantee but we do work with even
bigger employers than we used to you
know actually put you in jobs and so you
know coming from you know not in Udacity
and you know starting as a proper you
know partner the partner I was with we
hired multiple people from Udacity based
on their you know enrollment in the
self-driving car nano degree I've seen a
lot of other people get higher and do
interviews really what it kind of it is
it comparable other courses I would say
it's a hard number to track and to be
honest I don't have a good metric for
doing that because if you go and land a
job whether it's you know with one of
our partners or with somebody else the
only way that I know that is if you tell
me that and if you don't fill out the
surveys we send to you then I have a
hard time telling if you got a job or
not we do see great numbers but we also
know that more many more people are
getting jobs in and reported to us
because I personally have friends that
are getting jobs that aren't added into
our numbers so best thing you can do for
us is to help feeding that we know when
you get those service and you complete
these terms and when you do take a new
job feed that that stuff back to us I
mean do it be it on slack if you have to
you know message me on slack or whatever
you have to do we want to hear those
students stories so as you get through
your nano degree with robotics or
whatever else you
you know program you're in we want to
hear that because we do want to push you
know make those numbers known what level
look hold on what level of Python
experience is required to be successful
in the standard degree is knowledge
experience and C++ sufficient or is
Python a must Python so in my opinion if
you know one language really well you
can do any other language especially if
you're going from C++ to Python Python
is actually really easy to pick up the
syntax is really nice I mean you don't
have and it does a lot of things for you
that you see and it abstracts a lot of
things that C++ you have to deal with so
if you're good to C++ I think you'll be
fine with Python just maybe take a
couple of videos watch some stuff you
might have to Google things a little bit
more but I don't think you'll have an
issue so reinforcement learning I don't
so the question is how much is
reinforcement learning implemented in
robotics and what type of applications I
can't exactly speak on how how much is
penetrated the field but one really cool
area that I've saw is our you know our
partner Nvidia they showed off a new
simulator they have Isaac and they were
showing this robotics arm that would hit
a hockey puck into a net and they were
using reinforcement learning through
simulation to Train this so you know
certain tasks like that maybe
reinforcement learning a better four but
again that's I think what's the the the
field is still investigating what
actually makes sense to throw
reinforcement learning deep learning
you know convolutional neural networks
what's problems that it solves do you
have a hiring recruiting program
recruiting partners outside of the US
market we do I'm trying to think under
abut robotics if we do give me two
seconds to look at something we do value
I mean we do value our international
students so we do want to make sure that
everybody gets the same opportunities
and that we can partner with
you know people that are outside of just
the US however the u.s. does have a lot
of a lot of different partners and jobs
that you know know who Udacity is in can
reach out and reach out to us yeah we do
have even right here I mean I see
there's some companies especially cuca
they make the robotic arm they're a
partner I think they're at a Germany but
yeah there's a lot of partners that we
have internationally do both firms need
to be taken consecutively or can there
be a gap due to employment demands of
travel I would say if you can take them
consecutively that's great because
you're already in the method of studying
and you have your habits down but
there's nothing that says you can't join
it a later date so once you complete
term one you can totally join it to term
to covert later on
do you use recommend any robotics kits
for use throughout the course so we will
be releasing the Udacity robotics kit we
haven't announced yet but it's our
hardware that we're planning to ship for
term 2 but if you want to play with
things on your own I would say start
with something that had then you can
lease put Ross on once you've learned
how you can use Ross and do that then
you can take it to other club of your
platforms and do whatever whatever else
you would like to do with that and
personally I like Sparkfun for finding a
lot of cool things but what are the
possibilities of hiring in Pakistan I
couldn't find some hiring partners or
companies from Pakistan in the field of
self-driving cars or robotics I actually
don't know what the robotics industry
looks like in Pakistan if there are
hiring partners out there that are
looking to field a lot of jobs we'd be
absolutely happy to talk with them and
you know get partnerships in place but
I'm not aware of a robotics company
that's looking for that but feel free to
let me know if you know of one to what
depth or control algorithms be covered
for example will the nanodegree cover
concepts like state space modules or
pole placement for controls I can say I
think I'd have to actually ask my
curriculum lead on that one to see if he
has
well what they're looking or covering in
that unfortunately I don't have a good
answer for you since that contents not
quite out yet your student in the first
cohort looking due for a career change
how can you dasa T in this robotics and
a degree help you you're from India
well welcome I'm sure India has you know
some applications of these I don't know
the extent of those but yeah I mean
again we do Career Services in the
classroom and so when you want to review
your resume your LinkedIn things like
that we offer those services that you
can submit to us and we'll get feedback
on and that's at least one step to help
you there and then the best thing is I
can say is you know if you have local
meetups in your area or were your
country or whatever wherever you can go
to find these local meetups of people
that are like-minded networking is
extremely important so find out the
roboticists find people in the field and
talk to them find out what they're
looking for find maybe their company's
hiring and they have something that they
can link you up with so but Udacity will
help you on the careers front and then
again our resumes or your profile as
long as you're you know willing to share
it which is in your settings it goes out
to our employers and so our employers
can contact you for that robo still a
little early so that hasn't happened yet
but it will I would like to know or I'd
like to try the knowledge from term one
what open-source modules our models do
you recommend don't exactly know what
you mean about that or if you're talking
about
so gazebo is something we use in the
classroom and in our simulators and
gazebos open source and there's a lot of
resources or gazebo so if you're trying
to do something in Ross feel free to
find something that's compatible with
that if that's not what you mean please
type something else and I'll try to
answer that what beer am i drinking uh
this is a bear republic racer five IPA
yeah I'm not a huge IPA fan but it's all
we had in the fridge and it's it's not
bad
and this one's a twenty First Amendment
black and black not open yet but that's
the next one if this one goes empty
do you open-source projects
oh sorry jumped again label out
do you open-source projects during your
work the way do you use open-source
project during your work sure I mean we
tried to use open source things all of
our github Zoar public and so when you
sign up the course in your doing these
projects all of that stuff is out there
and we do like to try to we do like to
try to find that kind of we like open
source it's good why did you choose a
career in robotics good question so my
backgrounds in computer engineering I
have actually two bachelor's and
Bachelor of Science in Computer
Engineering and then my master's in
computer engineering and when I was in
college
I kind of was exploring the field seeing
what was out there and learning a bunch
of stuff and I thought one of the first
areas I looked into was nanotechnology
and I thought nanotechnology was really
cool and I wanted to learn more about it
and I went and talked to you know the
head of our department and turns out we
had a really cool like state-of-the-art
nanotechnology lab so I went and I met
with a professor and he gave me a tour
and explained everything about it and I
thought I was fascinating and I didn't
want to do anything with all with it so
I really quickly learned to like
identify what I like you know what I
thought was cool investigate a little
bit and find out if I actually liked it
or not and luckily I came across
robotics and started my sophomore year
you know doing build my FIRST robotics
my sophomore robotics project my
sophomore year in college and then
continued building one basically every
year until then and I just really loved
the field I looked you know I'm a
hands-on person so I like working with
my hands I like building something I
like the electrical aspects of it like
soldering and then I like the coding
aspect of it too and making everything
work together and then at the end of the
day it moves and it does something
physical and to me that was really
fascinating and so robotics has always
drawn me in and so I love robotics I
love self-driving cars I love everything
around that space so it's extremely
interesting to me if you pay for one
nano grade do you have access to all
other nano degrees nope right now you
just get the Nano grew you pay for
what is the Beth Platt best path to a
great robotics career uh worked really
hard and do awesome robotics projects
and find a position you really like
doing and excel in it I mean if you
don't really like it it's not gonna be a
great job if you're not gonna excel in
your career so I mean the best thing I
can say is do what you love and if
that's robotics and find out what about
robotics you like get a job doing it
start with our course you know learn
what you can there and if there's
something else you want to learn if you
want to do mechanical design on robotics
take a mechanical course there's there's
a lot around it so it's it really
depends on what you want to do I was
accepted to the term starting this month
but I'm considering holding off until I
find some more free time if I declined
the acceptance for the upcoming term and
I guaranteed a spot for a later date so
I believe in the emails and if you
didn't see this in the emails make sure
you talk to somebody on slack you should
have gotten the option to pay for the
core report right now or put it you know
a deposit down for the September cohort
so if you do that you'll be you know you
have your spot sealed for September if
you don't do either one then
unfortunately you have to go through the
application process again well Udacity
offer any scholarships of self-driving
car or about robotics nano degree in the
near future I would have to check with
our self or with their scholarships team
to find out about that we have in the
past I know for self-driving car offered
those but I'm not sure where that
currently sits what percentage of
enrollees complete the course in general
and self-driving car and machine
learning courses I don't know if we I
don't know if I can talk about those
numbers so we'll skip over that question
but we actually see but we see quite a
bit of people completing it and you know
self-driving car has been our longest
program and it's really exciting that
the people that have made it all the way
through have gone into term three now
and they're gonna be putting their code
on the car here in a matter of weeks and
we actually have beta testers testing
that out right now and so yeah our first
graduates within the next couple months
you'll see the first graduates come
a self-driving car which is really
exciting terms of the AI and robotics
revolution how far close do you think we
are from the AI robotics being used as
Udacity instructors and content
developers or generally as AI in the
education space so actually I think
that's one area where teachers are
probably in one of the safest positions
and you know if with Udacity as well you
can't you know we try to teach everybody
in many different ways and so you know a
physical in-person teacher tries to
adapt their curriculum to you know hit
as many people as possible but then it
can also adapt on a personal level I
don't think we're quite at that point
where robotics or AI is you know able to
supplement or starting out supplement
they can definitely supplement but they
can't replace the educator yet we'll see
how that is I mean it's in a really
exciting field and we haven't hit the
glass ceiling yet so it's really
interesting to see what will go if we
complete the Robotics nano degree where
we have access to the material to the
materials forever as they evolve in the
future you will so that's one of the
cool things about our program is that
you know people are kind of disappointed
that if they don't pass or they if they
don't complete the nano degree they lose
access to it and we do that because you
know our students who have completed the
program have now earned this credential
and we're gonna keep updating we're
gonna keep adding more to the curriculum
you know our products are kind of a
living you know thing and unlike a
university curriculum so they change
they improve and if you pass then
absolutely you're going to have that
access if you don't complete the
projects though you will lose that
access well I'd be able to create an
actual moving robot after the course so
this gets into what you currently know
and what we teach so we again teach more
of the software algorithms and
intelligence side for robotics and there
are platforms that you could get that
you could apply these things to if you
have never really done Linux computing
if you don't know how to do certain like
compiling or cross compiling
it depends on what level you're trying
to get into if you want to build
something from scratch you're gonna need
a little bit more than just the software
side of things required knowledge to
start with AI and robotics again some
basic you know not basic but up to
calculus or linear algebra math and then
programming in C++ or Python we
recommend for our course and for general
robotics but you know whatever you know
some course or some kind of language
that you're familiar with what is my
favorite tattoo my favorite tattoo is
actually on my back so you don't get it
see my favorite tattoo but yeah there's
some what I got I'm on the self-driving
car nanodegree you think it's great
perception is that my perception is that
in robotics there are a lot of
assignments in common is that so wait is
it required to go through all lessons
even after doing this self-driving car
so yes it is required to go through all
lessons and while some of the content
overlaps a little bit there is a
difference in the the projects and the
flavor of the content so one of the
things we want to do is we want to get
our projects to be different across our
nanodegrees and make sure that they're
different cuz if you are paying for
multiple nanodegrees doing those
projects is a really good challenge for
you and something for you to go and now
show off in your portfolio so there may
be some overlap but you would be
expected to complete all of them and you
because they are different projects what
do I think is the most promising area of
robotic in robotics well most promising
are Marc's most exciting I mean
manufacturing is probably the most
promising because it's already happening
you're gonna keep seeing it there it's
only gonna happen more and more takes
you know these hard laborious jobs out
of you know it takes them off of workers
hands but some of those jobs are really
hard look at some of the reports that
Tesla's had from its factories and so by
you putting more robots in those
factories you take humans out of harm's
way
a little bit more to me the more
exciting piece is I guess to space
applications just because I'm kind of a
space geek too and being able to put
things out into space and communicate
with them and have them do something is
really exciting
is there an online community of people's
success after receiving a degrees in
self-driving cars well nobody's received
a standard agree in self-driving cars
yet so I guess there's not a community
around it but we do have our slack
channels how many students per cohort in
the ramp how many students per cohort of
the robotics and a degree how many
applicants again those were members that
we don't completely touch on so right
now I'm in I'm learning machine learning
at Udacity well it helped me get into
robotics and how can I help get a job
what kind of robotic we're kind of jobs
will be there will there be as a
computer scientist student in robotics
so if you're a machine learning if
you're taking our machine learning nano
degree absolutely that's gonna set you
up for robotics there's gonna be things
that you're gonna learn in robotics that
aren't covered in there which would be
the whole reason of taking it but yeah
if you're successful and you get your
machine learning and a degree then I
would say you're gonna get accepted to
the robotics and a degree and if you
don't well then you should just probably
slack me because we probably should have
accepted you because you've completed
one of our other advanced nano degrees
but is a computer scientists I think are
if you want on the computer science side
our program directly lines up to that
because it is the AI and the artificial
intelligence they've kind of like it's
applying all of that into the very
robotics so if that's what you're
looking for those are the kind of you
know path planning localization slam
controls all of that stuff we definitely
you know the robotic community
definitely needs people who are computer
scientists in that what is my favorite
robotics movie ooh
well first one that comes to mind is
chappie I really like chappie it was
kind of it was different and weird and
kind of funny and so it was I enjoyed
that one I don't know if I have another
good one to name off the top of my head
though there's a lot of them
transformers are getting a little played
out though time committee need to be the
robotics no degree again we're looking
at about 10 to 15 hours that's gonna
gate like depend on your experience
that's going to move upward
how to start working on hands-on
robotics projects outside of school so
you could so if you're in school and I
see your next questions about mechanical
core so if you want to do the mechanical
side of things I recommend learning a
CAD program I am NOT a mechanical
engineer but I've played around with
SolidWorks so if that's the tool you
want to use and I know they have a good
student discount that you can download
SolidWorks and their tutorials are
really good so if you wanted to get into
the CAD side of things you know that's
what I would personally recommend and
then if you like depending on the area
that you're in look to see if there's
you know what do they call them the
different like hobbyist communities that
you can go to and work with 3d printers
and the different labs and workspaces so
if you can find one of those in your
area that would be great too most a
robotics career seemed to prefer
candidates at least to bachelors of
computer science do you think it is
necessary to learn the necessary skills
so a traditional background gives you a
lot of the theory Udacity doesn't cover
a lot of theory because our programs are
shorter but we give you a lot of the
application and we touch on the theory
but it depends when you get to a job
you're not always doing theory you're
expected to apply something and so
that's why a lot of our candidates and
why are a lot of our partners like our
programs because when a student comes
out of university they kind of know some
things but they may not have know how to
apply it all coming out of our program
you've done projects you can show that
you've done these projects you could
talk about them in a certain way and so
when you're given something you can go
and you can problem solve that project
so I think that some employers are gonna
be looking for that but there are a lot
of people that are looking that are more
interested in your skills versus the
degree you have how important is
programming and robotics absolutely
important if you don't program robotics
it program in robotics you basically
just have a box of parts so kind of need
to do a little bit of that and the thing
jumped against a hold on
would you recommend this cat course
instead of other AI courses I would
recommend this course if you want to do
robotics because it will teach you
artificial intelligence applied to
robotics if you want to do like natural
language processing and you want to
apply certain things you know you want
to design something like Alexa then this
probably isn't exactly going to be what
you're looking for but if you like the
idea of mobile robotics and that'd be
that drones self-driving cars robotic
arms any of those areas then absolutely
this is where you want to take it how
complete will the full course be for
example creating project documents
strength of materials mass production
create a robot from scratch or a
complete or partial design so we aren't
doing anything from here's your idea or
concept and here's how you take it to
production that's a really great concept
and I think that's an exciting area to
explore but that's outside of the scope
of our program again we're focused more
on the applied artificial intelligence
and robotics
are there any robotics ethics committees
that regulate the rapid process progress
of AI robotics a lot of Facebook's AIS
that make a new secret language there
are I can't give you any names but I
know that you know even Elon Musk that's
one of his big things so there's a lot
looking into that I just don't have
names for those for you sorry about that
who is the best cartoon robot bender
it's gotta be bender
I mean dear come on do robotics
nanodegree grads maintain access yep so
we if you graduate you will maintain
access to the course material and the
way I view that by the way is kind of
like you wouldn't a creek you're in a
school there's a as an alumni of a
certain school you get certain
privileges as a dropout you really don't
get it so if you're unable to complete
one of our programs you know we do give
an option of you know extensions
and we manage those in different ways
but they're very limited and the goal is
to get you to complete the program and
if you're unable to complete it you know
you can go and pay for the course again
or you know I guess try to complete it
in the same in the timeline but yeah we
don't have we do you know you do lose
access if you don't complete the
material we have deep learning part in
the robotics nanodegree program is it
the same as Suraj's deep learning so we
do have a part in there it is not the
same as Suraj's deep learning it is more
based on segmentation so if you're
familiar with that concept that should
be what its gonna cover whether any
courses coming based on natural language
processing or which course is currently
good for ones doing natural language
processing you have to look at them
because they're not in my wheelhouse but
I think it's either AI or machine
learning I want to say it's machine
learning does natural language
processing so if you're looking to do
that I would check that course out I
want to learn Python do you have that we
do intro to programming intro to program
we'll teach you a lot about programming
concepts including Python makerspaces
yep thanks today I was there a comment
earlier that I couldn't think of the
name my first year electrical
engineering undergrad what are some
courses that I should take to get a good
foundation in robotics so if you're a
first year electrical engineering
undergrad and I'm gonna be a little
biased on this may if you really like
robotics computer engineering to me is
more important because not only do you
learn about the electrical engineering
side of things but you're gonna learn
about how the software interfaces with
that electrical engineering and the
hardware side so any course that you can
see any course on embedded systems on
some algorithms on real-time operating
systems if you want to get into that
those are good courses to kind of look
into what kind of projects will help get
a job in robotics for projects besides
nanodegrees should I work on
great question so this is a good time to
tell a story of one of our students
Glenn Cameron Glenn was he's a robotics
student right now in the first cohort
based on so if you if you haven't joined
a slack channel definitely join our
slack channel and there's a channel in
there called build and brag that we want
to see what you're doing and you know
the cool robotics projects you're doing
and so Glenn posted his robotic arm that
he's built from scratch in this and he's
modeled in gazebo and it was just really
fascinating project and I really liked
it and we were going to TechCrunch
Disrupt or sorry TechCrunch robotics out
at MIT and I thought it was a perfect
time to take one of our students out
there with us based on the hard work
that they'd been doing on the side so I
invited Glenn out there he flew out
there we covered all of his costs to
come out there and join us out there and
his robot was featured on the Udacity
table that you know an MIT conference
basically TechCrunch MIT conference and
while he wasn't exactly looking for a
job he had a lot of job offers coming
his way he had a lot of attention it had
a lot of it just really a good attention
behind that you know his concept and
what he was doing so go off on your own
do I mean be creative I mean that's what
people want to see you be creative and
solve problems and even if you haven't
solved even if you haven't done it
perfectly or even if you haven't
completed I mean the robotic cam that he
did wasn't a hundred percent of the time
and like my senior design project when
we did our robot it wasn't a hundred
percent but we had designed everything
and we had had it working but we had
parts issues and we were able to talk
through all this stuff and so that
experience gives you a whole lot that
you can now bring to the table to your
employer so the best thing I can say is
to be creative and do something that you
really love because if you don't love it
you're not gonna finish it you're not
you're gonna hit stroke it's gonna be
hard at some point and you're not gonna
push through it so do something that you
really like doing do I need a pre
proficient in hardware skills in order
to get a job in robotics or will
software skills be sufficient again it
depends on what you want to do if you
want to do applied artificial
intelligence and robotics then
software's gonna be fine if you want to
develop more of a full software stack or
robotics stack then you should know some
more about their hardware but again
there's many
mechanical engineers who have no idea
anything about the software that work in
robotics so there's many different areas
and that kind of gets back into my point
of if you're a specialist or a
generalist well there'd be a revisit to
the projects on how to do them to a
production level algorithmically and
with time efficiency mass production in
time not in this nano degree this nano
degree is not that's kind of outside of
this the focus of what we're looking at
doing but I do think that's interesting
do we think it is it is it an important
concept to people and you can start you
can put some comments in here and I can
look at it later is it important to take
you know to have something that would
take your idea from you know here's an
Arduino prototype that I built - here's
a full production model that I can sell
let me know if you think that's
interesting because that's something
that I think is interesting are megabots
cool absolutely they're gonna go fight
Japan that's just cool nothing against
Japan I hope Japan has a really cool
solution - can we list the kinds of jobs
that are very demanding in the world
market as a computer engineer so
computer engineers are very
multi-disciplined and so I guess there's
a lot of jobs I started working in
Satellite you know in the satellite
world and so you a lot of embedded
systems you think of the Internet of
Things ever there's a processor and
there's software going on to everything
right now so I mean as a computer
engineer I think there's just a lot that
you can do so again it's really hard to
say it's really what you like doing just
because something's in demand doesn't
mean you like doing it so maybe maybe
you don't want to do it it won't be fun
in the US employers don't care about
nano degree is it not well-known isn't a
degree helping get a job so that's not
entirely true I mean you look at some of
our big name partners and we do have
employers that are hiring based on the
nanodegree work and you know I did work
for a large very large company before
this that is not a Silicon Valley based
company and they we I guess said we
hired you know people based on this now
I brought the attention to the company
because I knew what a nano degree was
and I was able to show them what that
was and what the value was but we have a
lot of we have a lot
big companies we have a lot of partners
we have a lot of people that are very
interested in the skill sets we teach so
I think it is helping to get a job and I
think it is it's not completely I mean
it's not as known as like a bachelor's
degree everybody knows what that is but
the nano degree is getting out there
what is the most complex robot I have
worked on um personally or
professionally or personally because I
can talk about those a little bit more
probably so for one of my senior design
projects or for my senior design project
or and you know near the end of my you
know 10 year University I built a and
we're gonna team led the team building a
drone basically that would use an Xbox
Kinect to map out three-dimensional
imagery so we did everything from the
ground up from concept level to carbon
fiber molding to algorithms to
integration to every yeah everything we
wrote the remote communication software
piece and so the team I had was awesome
and we worked you know really long hours
and really you know a lot of work went
into that thing and it was if one you
know the students choice of word at one
the top choice for the projects we were
able to fund the entire project
ourselves based on calls that I was a
basically business development side that
I was able to you know get done and so
it was it was an amazing project to do
and so it was you know fantastic working
with the team and being able to do that
and so the a lot went into it was pretty
complex very multi-layered using many
different languages to communicate on
different levels and a lot of fun really
really fun how is project management at
Udacity great I really like it here I
it's a different world from what I've
came from before but I'm really enjoying
my time here and very happy to be here
you just enrolled in the robotics and a
degree blue Congrats thanks for
answering all these questions oh well
I'm excited you're getting excited next
week - not really a question but I'm
really excited to hear that what scene
design robotics projects did you do an
undergrad so I just talked about that
how was Boston TechCrunch robotics day
it was awesome it was really cool too
a lot of projects unfortunately I got
stuck not listening to as many talks as
I wanted to and Manning more of a booth
but that's okay I had a lot of fun made
a lot of good contacts and that was
actually my first time out in Boston so
it was a fun time to explore if you
build a depth very robot should you post
it and build and brag yes cuz I want to
see it what hardware do you see being
simulated in software that's
cutting-edge or surprises you um
actually I think Nvidia is a really cool
if you're not familiar with it the tx2
platform I think is extremely
interesting and capable and so they are
simulating that in their the Isaac the
Isaac simulator they're gonna be coming
out with I believe they're simulating
that it hasn't been out yet but so you
can't simulate a lot of things and so
I'm to me that's a cutting-edge platform
I don't think there's anything else like
that on the market so I really like the
TX to graduate and mechanical
engineering zero knowledge on
programming and have an idea of building
an AI autonomous quadcopter with vision
systems generate okay so if you have no
programming knowledge at all
intro programming would be good because
it's going to touch on programming
concepts in many different facets and
then Python you know you'll learn a
little bit of Python and then again it's
still a leap to go from there to the
robotics program but keep an eye out
we're working on ways to we can make
more of a you know transition from you
know nothing to 100 so does of course
cover any of the electronic theory and
its terms basically it doesn't know
sorry I feel the gap between indie
projects and how to get them into
production as a gap in the gravel face
yeah so there is a gap to getting in
production but that's your you go to a
company whether you come out of
university or you come out of a nano
degree they don't expect you to know how
to get it into production and that's
usually not the you know individual
contributors role to make sure that it's
getting into production there's you have
many other experienced people that are
working on that product ization of it so
I wouldn't be too worried about that
unless you're trying to make something
on your own you know you should
understand why
goes into it if you can understand some
of the production to like what goes into
like you know from A to B you know but I
wouldn't worry too much about that and
we jump over time one can I predict the
outcome of two football teams games
using a feed-forward neural network
maybe I don't really know try it out and
see if it predicts correctly what's the
best way to learn about our tosses
that's a good question I haven't played
a whole lot with them one podcast that I
really like personally listening to is
called embedded they talked about a lot
of the tools that are used in in the
embedded world in our tosses and things
like that and they do link to a lot of
different things so I don't personally
have a good recommendation other than
the podcast but check that out you
mentioned that nanodegree helped you get
a job that there are no statistics about
percentages people being employed so we
do have some internal statistics about
the percentage of people being employed
what I was saying is that I don't think
that there well I know that they're not
accurate because I don't even think I
maybe have been I know people who
haven't fill out the survey or you know
people that have just gotten jobs that
aren't maybe with one of our partners
but got it as a direct relation from the
self-driving car nanodegree program and
so it's hard to track those people and
so that's one of the challenges that I'm
looking at is how do we figure out
somebody who's taking a job whether it's
with one of our partners or somewhere
else how do we capture that information
so that we can produce accurate
statistics so it's a hard it's a hard
thing problem-solve
[Music]
how to get a full scholarship for the
robotics and a degree keep an eye out
I'm not too sure again we have a
robotics or we have a scholarship teams
that works on all that is the robotics
Lac open to students of other Native
degrees I'm currently in term to SCC it
is I believe Kyle a few crew if you're
still on if you could link it otherwise
let me look real quick it is Udacity -
robotics slack comm and so
you can join that that's open to
everybody Hey look Kyle beat me to it
sorry I'm getting through these kind of
linearly who's the who who who who are
the who's who of the robotics nanodegree
uh you mean company wise or do you mean
as far as our team you've clarified that
a little bit not try to answer before we
get off here
should I learn Arduino for AI flight
simulation or Raspberry Pi for of a
quadcopter so Arduino is okay but
Arduino is Arduino is just it's not
you're not going to get a job off of an
Arduino project so with the Raspberry Pi
at least you can put Ross on there and
that's kind of what we teach in our
curriculum so can can I help you out
with what features to use for training
on the football like I think that's the
question I think if you figured out what
features to use and you could accurately
predict that you would make tons of
money on them you know if you could
predict the outcome of football games so
I don't have a good answer for that good
luck though and if you do let me know
best courses which you could learn from
Udacity for AI swarm cod quad copters I
don't think we actually touch on
anything swarm yet it is a topic that I
think is very interesting but I don't
have a good solution for to give you for
that yet oh and I'll talk to my Kyle
here it's robotics or it's you Udacity -
robotics
oh that aleikum ok cool awesome he's got
it and one of the main people at Udacity
we should know in the robot Hana degree
so if you're in the slot channel you
know Mike Salem
he's our student services lead he's
great tries to introduce you know talk
to everybody I was coming in and he's
your point if you have any problems like
he will definitely try to address those
first we've also got Ryan who's our
curriculum lead right now that you've
seen on camera
everybody else is kind of more behind
the scenes so you probably won't see
them out there as much if you want to
know more people I can go through a list
of people but we I mean we have a really
great team here for the Robo but it's
not that's it's not that interesting
maybe it's interesting to you let me
know if it is asked back to the beer
question again this was a racer 5 IPA
and this one's like which I probably
have to open up but back in black 21st
amendment
brewery I need to bring some where I'm
from Colorado so New Belgium all the way
but this is what I got stuck with got
advice of someone completely new to
software engineering and I'm gonna start
wrapping up these questions here because
we're gonna be wrapping up here in a
second
completely new to software engineering
I'm looking to land a job in the field
you have to get a little bit more X is
specific with that I don't know what
you're talking about is like do you know
software engineering yet you've
completed a degree you've completed a
nano degree but again if you're looking
to land a job do something that sets you
apart get become like get a really good
story to tell
work on a project solve problems even if
you aren't successful in them being able
to talk about how you thought through it
because what what a hiring manager wants
to know is can you problem-solve
can I throw a problem in front of you
and can you think through it in the
right way to be successful of that so
that's a really important skill I'm
enrolled in the M I am L and the deep
learning on degrees what should be my
strategy towards my career I want to do
AI then agreed to should I look at jobs
first or complete an AI nano degree I
will never tell you to not be looking at
jobs I mean I know people who have who
were in term one and self-driving car
and got jobs because they just started
looking so absolutely I apply out there
see what you can if you're not getting
hits keep going I mean and even if you
do get your first job keep going through
another nano degree because I was
employed I wasn't looking to make a move
and I took this Australian car one I
just wanted to learn a little bit more
about the field that I was already in so
continue to do any further further
courses to get better at Ross so ours is
great but there's also I think the
RAAF's course if you go to those
tutorials go through those tutorials on
the raw side those are really good
- can I share my height weight shoe size
perception will predict my gender I hope
you can predict my gender if not then I
think you need to work on some more
machine learning algorithms can the next
robots a beer and robots include a beer
pouring robot we'll see I'll see if I
can get time to do anything with that
recommended skills for learning the
electrical side so I really like spark
fun they have some tutorials on
soldering and things like that so check
out their site do you think the course
is doable for people who work full time
absolutely I was doing the self-driving
car course working full time almost
everybody I know is either a student or
has a job and is doing you know
nanodegrees full-time so I don't need a
job I'm an entrepreneur so you could you
please suggest a better way to start
with Arduino or Raspberry for copter so
it depends on there's a lot there's
there's a whole lot that goes into that
that could be a whole other discussion
about what you'd actually want to apply
if you know yeah it's there's a lot look
what I can add like it looks like house
linking some stuff look up look at
projects and see if something that you'd
want to do an emulate so don imus drones
are controlled Don Imus I think will be
the future but anyways looks like that's
caught up with all the questions it's 9
o'clock our time and so thank you for
joining me
Cheers and I hope you can join us next
time for our next beer inbox thank you
you